The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So again, this
is one more question on
hybridization.
This is the last question you'll
get on hybridization
before you see the exam.
So now we're talking about
hybridization of two different
atoms in a molecule.
So we're looking at
this carbon atom
here and this nitrogen.
So using the rules that we've
learned in terms of doing this
quickly, let's see if you can
get these answers in quick.
So let's go ahead and just take
10 more seconds on this
question here.
Your parents are free to help
if they're here with you.
OK.
Excellent. excellent
job, 98% of you.
You're a lot louder with the
parents here, so let's make
sure we're still listening.
OK, so let's go over what we
just we just established here.
Carbon a is going to be
s p 3 hybridized.
What is the geometry, what's
the vsper geometry there?
Good, it's tetrahedral.
And this nitrogen b here, that's
s p 3 hybrid as well.
What's the geometry around
that nitrogen?
Trigonal pyramidal, right.
We have to take into account
the fact that there's that
lone pair there.
All right, so let's go ahead and
switch over to the lecture
notes and see what
we just did here.
And essentially actually what
we just did was I had you
identify two of four components
that make up what's
called the morphine rule.
And the morphine rule is a set
of structural elements that
are responsible for the
biological activity of
morphine and other morphine-like
drugs that have
a similar pharmacological
activity in terms of how
they're active.
So specifically, the morphine
rule is a set of four
components, which start with the
phenyl ring here, so, an
aromatic ring.
The second thing you identified,
which is an s p 3
hybrid carbon.
And then following that we have
a c h 2 c h 2 group here.
And the last part of the
rule is this s p
3 hybridized nitrogen.
So, in terms of thinking about
what this means, I said this
is responsible for the
biological activity of morphine.
If we take a look at the
morphine molecule here, what
you can see is that it's a
little bit more complicated
than this structure that
we see right here.
But if I go ahead and highlight
the residues in
purple, you can see that it,
in fact, does follow the
morphine rule.
And what this means is this
is what allows morphine to
actually bind into its receptor,
which is a pain
receptor and block the
feeling of pain.
So that's a very important thing
in terms of thinking
about hybridization in geometry,
because we've
actually established a very
important structure and shape,
which is this morphine rule
here, that if it's found in a
molecule, as long as there
aren't other parts of the
molecule that are messing up
that interaction, we can
actually form a very
tight binder
into these pain receptors.
So morphine, as you know, is
a very potent pain killer.
But you also, I'm sure, know
that it's also very addictive,
so it's only used sparingly in
terms of treating pain in a
general sense, and it's always
used in very closely-monitored
situations in terms
of hospital care.
But what's interesting to take
note of is that the bioaction
of morphine is very similar to
endorphins that we naturally
biosynthesize.
Endorphins have a structure
that's very similar to this
structure up here -- endorphins
are small peptide
molecules that we biosynthesize
and have in very
low concentrations
in our brain.
They bind to pain receptors and
block those pain receptors.
So, when someone talks about an
endorphin high, which you
sometimes get -- one example
would be the runners' high, if
you run for a long way running
fast, eventually you'll hit
that runner's high where you get
this burst of endorphins.
All of a sudden your feet don't
hurt, your shins don't
hurt, the pain goes
away and you got
this feeling of eurphoria.
It's the exact same interaction
and it's because
of that structure there.
It's not exactly the morphine
rule in endorphins but it's
very similar.
So, if we look at other
derivatives of morphine, such
as codeine and diacetylmorphine,
these also
you can see have this morphin
rule within them, this
structure that you've identified
using your vsper
rules and thinking about
hybridization.
Codeine, as you may know, is
less of a potent pain killer
compared to morphine, but it's
also less addictive.
So for that reason it's
prescribed with
slightly less oversight.
So if you get your wisdom teeth
removed or something
like that, some of you might
have had taken codeine before,
and now you can think about by
looking at the structure, a
little bit more about how
that worked in terms of
blocking your pain.
One that I just want to mention
because it's so
interesting is this derivative,
which is
diacetylmorphine.
The only difference between
morphine and diacetylmorphine
is the changing of an alcohol
group, or two actually, two
acetyl groups here.
This was synthesized by the
company Bayer, and you
probably know Bayer from
Bayer's aspirin.
Bayer had a huge success with
aspirin where they took
salicylic acid and replaced an o
h group with an acetyl group
here, and made acetylsalicylic
acid.
Does anyone know the common
name for that?
Yup.
So that's aspirin, and we often
think of Bayer's aspirin.
We associate it really
closely.
They worked really hard in
marketing to make that really
close association and with
copywriting, so that when we
think about aspirin we
think about Bayers.
Bayers also made this change
here, and they did find that
diacetylmorphine is much, much
more potent than morphine is.
They could use just a tiny, tiny
amount of this compound
and get the same pain-killing
properties that
they saw with morphine.
The problem is that this
masked some of the side
effects that they didn't realize
initially, which was
the extreme, extreme ability for
you to become addicted to
diacetylmorphine.
And this was first thought of as
a hero drug because it was
such a strong pain killer,
and this was
called a Bayer's heroin.
We don't usually associate the
name Bayers with heroin, like
we did with aspirin -- that's
because Bayers did not work so
hard to keep that association
there.
But it's an interesting story
from the history of drugs.
One more example I want to show
you is demerol, which is
used clinically quite often.
Demerol, if we look at the
structure here, actually looks
nothing like morphine at all.
So to an untrained eye,
you might not see the
relationship there.
But because you all know some
of these basic principles of
chemistry, you should be able to
pick out that morphine rule
right in the middle
of demerol.
And, in fact, demerol is
a pain killer, it's an
alternative to using morphine.
Again, not quite as strong as
morphine in terms of pain
killing abilities, but also not
as addictive either, and
there are some other side
effects, such as nausea that
are limited with demerol
compared to morphine.
Demerol has its own set of
problems, so it's not the
perfect solution to a different
alternative to
morphine, but you do see it
used in certain cases.
All right, so that's thinking
about vsper theory, and that's
thinking about hybridization.
We're now going to shift gears
to talking about some new
topics today.
So, we ended in Wednesday's
lecture with giving that set
of rules to very quickly
determine hybridization.
And then after we'd established
that, we moved on
to starting to talk about a
little bit of thermochemistry.
Specifically what we were
talking about is the
enthalpies of chemical
reactions, so either the
amount of heat that's released,
or the amount of
heat that's required
in order to have a
chemical reaction go.
And we'd established so far two
ways to think about how we
can measure what the overall
enthalpy of a reaction is.
And I just wanted to introduced
one more technique
that we can use to do that.
And this relies on the fact
that when we talk about
enthalpy or we talk about the
heat change of a reaction,
this is a state function, and
any time we're talking about
state function, it's independent
of path.
So essentially, all that we're
worried about is the state
that we started in.
So, for example, when we were
talking about the oxidation of
glucose, the state that we start
in are the reactants, so
it's glucose plus oxygen.
And what we ended up with were
six moles each of carbon
dioxide and water.
So, we don't care how we get
there in terms of making this
calculation, all we're
interested in is the
difference between those two
states, to think about the
overall change in enthalpy.
So, for example, when we talked
about how we could
calculate this, one way that we
can do it, and we'll look
at these numbers even more
specifically in a second, is
thinking about instead of going
straight down here,
which we might not have the
numbers available to us to
calculate directly, we can think
about well, what happens
if instead we break apart this
glucose molecule and decompose
it into its elements, because
using tables in the back of
our book, for example, we can
figure out what the change in
enthalpy is of this
reaction here.
That doesn't quite get us to
where we need to go though, so
then we can think about the
enthalpy of formation of six
carbon dioxide molecules.
And then we can go one step
further and think about the
enthalpy of formation for
six water molecules.
So this is just a round
about way of going
from here to here.
Instead we went up and then
down and then down, but
because it's a state function,
we're absolutely
allowed to do this.
And to formalize this, we can
talk about what's called
Hess's law.
And Hess's law just tell us that
if we have two or three
or any number of chemical
reactions that we can add
together in order to get the
chemical equation that we're
actually interested in, we can
figure out the change in
enthalpy of that reaction that
we're interested in, just by
adding together all of the other
enthalpies of reaction
for every other reaction that
we had to add together in
order to get there.
So, let's take a look at what
we're talking about here.
So when I just showed you that
example graphically, I'm just
writing it out more like an
equation here, because the
nice thing about Hess's law,
is it allows you to think
about chemical reactions kind
of as if they're algebraic
expressions.
So we can just add all of these
different expressions
together, and if we're thinking
about algebra, we can
just think about crossing things
out that are in the
reactants versus in
the products.
So if we do this, what we end
up getting is the reaction
that we're interested in, the
oxidation of glucose to form
carbon dioxide in water.
So let's look pretty carefully
at exactly the fact that these
all cancel out to give us the
reaction I say we get.
So, for example, we can think
about the oxygen molecules --
we can cancel out 6 here and 6
here, as long as we multiply
this whole reaction by 6.
Again, we can get rid of those
last 3 oxygen molecules there.
Similarly, we can cross out
our 6 hydrogens from the
products with 6 molecular
hydrogens from the reactants.
And then the last thing we can
cancel out are our carbon
atoms -- we have 6 in the
products, and we have 6 in the
reactants here.
So you'll see that the only
things that are not canceled
out is what's left in
our bottom reaction.
So we can go ahead and just add
up all of these different
reaction enthalpies.
In the first case what we're
going to have is an enthalpy
of 1260, and that's in
kilojoules per mole of glucose.
And the reason that this is
positive is because it's
essentially the reverse reaction
of the change in
enthalpy of formation.
So it's going to be a positive
number there.
We add to that the enthalpy for
this reaction here, which
is negative 393 .
5, but we need to remember to
multiply that by 6, because
we're actually adding
together six of
those individual reactions.
And lastly, we also add together
six of this final
reaction here, which has
an enthalpy change of
negative 285 .
8.
So if we go ahead and just add
up all of our individual
enthalpy changes, what we're
going to end up with for our
entire reaction here, is a
change in enthalpy of negative
2816, and that's kilojoules
per mole of glucose.
Does anyone remember from
Wednesday's class, does this
match what we had seen
experimentally?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so this is
the exact number that we
calculated when we used heats
of formation, and it's also
the exact number that's seen
in terms of experimental.
All right.
So there's actually three ways
we now have to calculate heats
of the change in enthalpy
of an overall reaction.
So, we have these in our notes
from last time and from
finishing the end of this unit
right now, but I'm just going
to summarize them for you on the
board, because there are a
couple things that can get
confusing that I want to make
sure no one is confusing,
particularly in
the upcoming exam.
So what was the first way that
we learned to think about
calculating enthalpies
of reaction?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Um-hmm.
So, it's talking about
bond enthalpies.
And when we talk about bond
enthalpy, the symbol that we
see for a bond enthalpy
is usually delta h.
And this is where all the
confusion starts, because
everything's delta h, it just
depends on the subscript here,
right, what kind of delta
h we're talking about.
In the case of bond enthalpy
often you'll see no
subscript at all.
But sometimes you do see a
subscript, which would then
just be delta h sub b here.
So if we're trying to do this
calculation based on bond
enthalpies, for the delta h for
an overall reaction, what
we want to do is take the
sum of all of those bond
enthalpies of our bonds that are
broken, and what we want
to do is subtract from that
the sum of all our bond
enthalpies of our bonds
that are formed.
All right, so let's think a
little bit more about what
this means.
So, if we're talking about bonds
broken, are we talking
about reactants or products?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: .
Reactants.
So, essentially we're summing
up the bond enthalpy of
reactants and subtracting
it from the products.
All right, great.
So that's our first
strategy there.
The second strategy that we
learned is thinking about bond
enthalpies of reaction by using
the enthalpy change in
terms of the enthalpy
of formation.
So this one is sometimes a
little bit more intuitive,
because we're talking about the
enthalpy change it takes
in order to form a
given molecule.
So, if we're trying to do a
calculation using enthalpies
of formation, what we find is
that delta h of the reaction
is equal to the sum of the
delta h of formation of
products or reactants?
STUDENT: Products.
PROFESSOR: Products, good.
Of products minus the delta h of
formation, and this is the
sum again of reactants.
All right, and our third
strategy is what we just
talked about, which is Hess's
law, and in fact, both one and
two are applications of Hess's
law -- specific applications,
but any application of Hess's
law you can use any way of
adding up different equations
to get the final enthalpy of
the reaction.
The reason I wanted to put these
two strategies, however,
on the board right next to each
other, is so we can just
confront a point of confusion
that happens a lot with
students, which is why in the
first case do we have
reactants minus product, and
in the second case we have
products minus reactants.
So, you need to keep these two
straight when you're doing
your calculations in terms of
enthalpies, and the reason is
because the definition of a
bond enthalpy when we're
talking about bonds, is the
enthalpy that it takes in
order to break the bond, the
amount of heat that goes in to
breaking a bond.
So it's typically a positive
number, because if you have a
stable bond you have to
put heat into it in
order to break it.
So you end up having a positive
bond enthalpy here.
In contrast, when we're talking
about enthalpies of
formation, now we're talking
about is the change of
enthalpy in order to
form a molecule.
So, for example, if we have a
nice stable molecule with
strong bonds in it, what we're
going to find is that the
delta h of formation, would that
be positive or negative?
So it's negative.
So you'd end up with a negative
delta h of formation.
So because you're talking about
a term that's negative
here where it would be positive
in the first case,
you end up flipping signs
to have it work out.
So, if this doesn't make sense
as I'm saying it right now,
just go back in your notes and
look through and make sure
that you aren't going to get
mixed up when you're using
bond enthalpies versus
enthalpies of formation here.
All right, so that's pretty
much all we're
going to say on enthalpy.
So I really just want to stress,
this is going to be
the end of exam 2 material
here, I said I'd be clear
about it in class today.
This is it.
It's also written in
your notes when
you go ahead to study.
So remember, in terms of exam 2,
which I'll remind you is on
Wednesday, it's going to be all
the way from the material
on lecture 10 up to
this point here.
So only through enthalpy, and
it's also going to be on
problem-sets four and five,
and I'll mention that this
afternoon, as I said, I'll post
a bunch of extra practice
problems, which are more review
of these same concepts,
so you can get even more
practice this weekend and
early next week to prepare.
All right, so that's enthalpy,
that's the
end of exam 2 material.
But there's actually another
really important concept that
we need to talk about -- we
really don't want to stop with
enthalpy, luckily it's exam 2
and not the end of the class,
because a really important
concept to think about is
spontaneous change.
So thinking about whether a
reaction is spontaneous or
non-spontaneous.
And when we think about a
spontaneous reaction, I think
this is a term many of you are
familiar with, spontaneous
just means that the reactions
going to proceed in the
forward direction without any
kind of outside intervention.
So thinking of a spontaneous
process, can talk about a
chemical reaction, but you
could just picture, for
example, putting a round rock
on the top of a hill -- it
will spontaneously just roll
right down that hill.
So a spontaneous process also
has direction, right, because
the rock won't spontaneously
roll back up the hill without
putting in work.
So essentially we're talking
about a spontaneous process
when something's going to happen
without actually having
to do anything else to
force it to happen.
So let's think about in terms
of chemistry what we're
talking about is a spontaneous
reaction -- that's the
specific type of spontaneous
process that
we're interested in.
So let's think about a few
different types of spontaneous
reactions, and see if we can
come up with some idea of
what's going to cause them
to be spontaneous.
So one spontaneous reaction is
written here, so this is just
the oxidation of iron, or the
formation of rust. This turns
out to also be an exothermic
reaction, it has a negative
delta h of 824 kilojoules
per mole.
Another spontaneous reaction
is written here, the
combination of an acid
and a base, which
neutralizes each other.
So we have a hydronium ion and a
hydroxide ion interacting to
form water.
This is spontaneous, and
again, it's exothermic.
So, its delta h is
negative 55 .
9 kilojoules per mole.
Let's think about some
really relevant
reactions in our bodies.
So one incredibly important
reaction, of course, is ATP
hydrolysis where we have
adenosine here, a
triphosphate, so we have three
phosphate groups here.
That's called ATP.
It has a total charge
of minus four.
So if we hydrolize this, one
of the phosphate bonds here
and lose a phosphate, we end up
with adenosine diphosphate
or ADP and that has a charge
of minus three.
Yup?
STUDENT: On our notes, this
equation [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Oh, no.
OK, thank you.
Which equation are
we talking about?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: I'm sorry, what
page are you on?
Page two.
So the one with h 3 --
OK.
All right, let's go
back to that.
OK, so if you can fix this
reaction in your notes here.
I'll also fix it on the website,
so if you don't want
to fix it now I'll just
re-post the notes.
So it should be four irons plus
three oxygens is two f e
2 o 3 solid.
Thanks for pointing that out.
All right, does everyone
have that down?
I know you had to flip
a page there.
All right, so I'll post
it in the notes if you
didn't get it there.
Let's go back to ATP
hydrolysis here.
So we're going from ATP to ADP,
and that is a spontaneous
process, and it's an exothermic
reaction as well.
So we find that it's negative
24 kilojoules per mole in
terms of the change
in enthalpy there.
All right, so at this point
I just showed you three
reactions where we have
something that's spontaneous
and it's also exothermic.
And I could show you a countless
number of other
reactions where it's
the same thing.
It's actually quite common
if you have an exothermic
reaction that it's also
spontaneous at room
temperature.
So we might start to draw the
conclusion that, in fact, it's
enthalpy that's responsible for
whether or not a reaction
is spontaneous or
non-spontaneous.
So it's very easy to get that
impression, but let me show
you a few more reactions
before we draw any
conclusions.
Let me show you some more
spontaneous reactions.
So, for example, the conversion
of solid h 2 o to
liquid h 2 o at room
temperature, I think we all
know this is spontaneous.
Ice melts at room temperature,
but it turns out that the
enthalpy change is positive,
it's 7 kilojoules per mole.
Similarly, if we look at this
reaction here, which is
ammonium nitrate.
This is a very commonly used
fertilizer, a very commonly
used nitrogen source
in agriculture.
If we think about solvating this
and forming the two ions,
ammonium ion and nitrate ion.
Again, this is a spontaneous
reaction, but what we find
here is that delta h again
is positive, it's also
endothermic.
So thinking about all of this,
would you say that enthalpy is
the key to spontaneity?
STUDENT: No.
PROFESSOR: No, it's definitely
not the key to spontaneity.
It tends to correlate in many
cases at room temperature, but
it is not the key
to spontaneity.
And the key to spontaneity is
instead something called Gibbs
free energy or delta g.
And if we think about what delta
g is, we can relate it
to enthalpy, and this will sort
of show us why there's
often this correlation, because
delta g is equal delta
h minus this term here, which
is temperature, and that's
temperature times a
change in entropy.
And we'll talk very in-depth
in just a few minutes about
what entropy actually is, but
for now I just want you to
think about the fact that in
addition to thinking about
enthalpy there's this
other term here
that comes into play.
So when we're talking about what
the sign about delta g is
or free energy is, some of you
might already be familiar with
this, when we're talking about
a negative delta g, is this
spontaneous or non-spontaneous.
So, maybe not so familiar,
which is totally fine.
So in terms of thinking about
a negative delta g, that's
going to be a spontaneous
process.
Any time you see a negative free
energy, which just like
when we talk about entropy, it's
a similar idea, it means
that free energy is released
as the reaction progresses.
That's going to be a spontaneous
process.
So that means that if delta g
is greater than zero, then
what we're going to see a
non-spontaneous process.
And finally in the case where
delta g is equal to zero, at
this point we're at equilibrium,
which basically
means that there's no net change
in either the forward
or the reverse reaction in
terms of thinking about
whether something's
spontaneous or not
spontaneous, it's just
at equilibrium
we see no net change.
And something I want to point
out is that this reaction is
valid only when where at
constant temperature and
pressure, which we will be
throughout the discussions in
this class in terms of
using this equation.
And also, it turns out that
when you do most chemical
equations, you are, in fact,
at a pretty constant
temperature, and a constant
pressure in terms of most
things are done in the open
atmosphere, so that's really
not going to change.
All right, so let's just talk
very briefly about why it is
that free energy is what
determines spontaneity, and
not this enthalpy here,
not what the
change in enthalpy is.
And it really comes in terms
remembering it in terms of the
definition.
When we think about delta g,
what that is is that it's
energy that's released or used
in the reaction, but if it is
released, that it can directly
be used to do work.
It's what we call free
energy -- it's
free to do other things.
Whereas when we were talking
about enthalpy here, well,
this is the amount of heat
that's released when we break
and form the bonds
in the reaction.
But some of it actually gets
stuck in the molecules, and
this is just a way to think
about it, this term here is
one way we can think about it,
it's just some energy that's
getting stuck.
So, for example, molecules,
which we don't really go into
in this class, have vibrational
movements, they
have rotational movements,
there's energy associated with
that that can sort of get stuck,
as we could say, some
of the enthalpy that's released
in terms of forming
and breaking the bonds
in a reaction.
So that's our case where we
could see that we have a
negative delta h, but we
still end up with a
positive delta g.
And again, I haven't really gone
into what entropy is here
yet, and we will just
in a few minutes.
But first, I want to take a look
at one of the examples
that we talked about, which is
the conversion of ammonium
nitrate when its solvated,
breaking up into its ions.
So what I had told you is
that, in fact, this is a
positive delta h, but still
that the reaction is
spontaneous.
So let's just do this
calculation and see if we can
confirm that in terms
of delta g.
So the reaction again that we're
going to use is delta g
equals delta h minus
t delta s.
So if we're talking about room
temperature here, so we're
going to say that delta g in
this case is going to be equal
to 28 kilojoules per mole,
minus -- we're at room
temperature or 298 kelvin -- in
this reaction, you always
put temperature into kelvin.
And then we need to multiply
it by the entropy, which is
109 joules per kelvin mole.
I want to point out that entropy
tends to be a much
smaller value than enthalpy,
so it's reported in joules
instead of kilojoules.
When you solve these problems,
it's really important to
convert it into kilojoules so
that your units work out and
you don't get a completely
crazy answer.
So we want to convert
this to 0 .
109 kilojoules per
kelvin mole.
So we can just re-write this,
so we have 28 kilojoules per
mole, then this term
here will be 32 .
5 kilojoules per mole.
So what we end up with our delta
g for this reaction is
going to be negative 4
kilojoules per mole.
All right, so talking about this
as a negative delta g,
would you say this is
a spontaneous or
non-spontaneous reaction.
Yeah, it's spontaneous.
So what we're going to see is
delta g is negative 4, so this
reaction is spontaneous
even though our
enthalpy change was positive.
Let's take a look at one more
reaction since we spent so
much time discussing the
oxidation of glucose.
So again, what we know about
this reaction, we've already
calculated the delta
h is negative 2816
kilojoules per mole.
And you could look up and
we'll figure out how to
calculate it soon, the change in
entropy, which is plus 233
joules per k mole.
So before we actually do this
calculation, let's go to a
clicker question and I want
you to think about what's
happening here.
So if you're thinking about the
oxidation of glucose and
what the sign is of the change
in enthalpy and the change in
entropy, which of these
statements is true.
Is it going to be spontaneous
at all temperatures,
non-spontaneous at all
temperatures, or will it
depend on the temperature
whether this reaction is
spontaneous or not
spontaneous?
So, remember this is our
relationship here.
So let's go ahead and just take
10 seconds on this one.
OK, so we have a pretty
mixed response here.
So this could have made or broke
the chances of your team
on the competition today, but
they'll be a few more left to
redeem yourselves if you
got it incorrect.
So what we're going to find is
that it's spontaneous at all
temperatures, and we can
actually just look at this
equation here to figure
out why that is.
If our reaction is spontaneous,
that means that
delta g is negative.
So in terms of delta h being
negative, well, that's going
to always contribute to delta
g being negative no matter
what the temperature is.
And if delta s is positive,
since it's minus t delta s,
and our temperature is always
positive because we're on the
kelvin scale, so it starts
at zero there, then this
component here is always going
to be negative as well.
So we're always going to have
two negative numbers so that
our combination, our delta g's
always going to be negative,
it's always going to
be spontaneous.
All right, so let's make sure
that's what we do see when we
calculate this for the oxidation
of glucose here.
So if we do this and we plug
in our numbers, we see that
delta g is going to be equal
to negative 2816 times the
temperature, room temperature,
times again,
remember to put 0.
233, because we need to
convert from joules to
kilojoules for our
entropy term.
So what we find out is that this
reaction has a delta g of
negative 2885 kilojoules
per mole.
This is a spontaneous
reaction.
All right, so let's get back
to that entropy term.
I introduced it without
explaining at all
what it really is.
So let's take a few moments
and think about entropy.
Entropy is actually a very easy
concept to think about,
it's a measure of disorder.
I think most of us have a very
good concept of how things
tend to go to disorder, so
it's something we can
conceptualize just in an
infinite number of ways.
And entropy is simply
a measure of the
disorder of a system.
And when we're talking about
chemical reactions, what we're
talking about is a change
in entropy.
So whether, as a reaction goes
forward, are we becoming more
ordered or are we becoming
more disordered?
So just like we saw for
enthalpy, entropy also is a
state function, so it doesn't
matter in terms of path how we
got from point a to point b.
All we need to worry about is
the current state of our
system, what the current
entropy is and take the
difference.
So, an example that I like to
use in terms of conceptually
thinking about what's going on
in terms of disorder, and
which is especially relevant
in New England is thinking
about stone wall.
So you can think about a stone
wall in terms of being very,
very ordered, right.
If you just built your stone
wall, every stone is in place,
it has a high degree of order.
So in other words, the
disorder is very low.
So it has a low entropy, a
low level of disorder.
But if we're looking at a New
England stone wall, which are
typically found if you're hiking
in the woods you see
ones that are just ancient and
are completely crumbling down,
you'll find that the stone wall
is no longer quite so
ordered as it was.
In fact, let's say there's a
few stones that have fallen
off, our disorder has increased,
so we end up
increasing the entropy.
And I do just want to point out
with this analogy that it
is a state function.
So for thinking about the change
in entropy, which is
this distance right here, we
can either calculate it
directly from here to here. but
it also doesn't matter,
let's say the wall crumbled down
completely and we ended
up having a very high degree of
disorder, if then someone
put most of the stones back in
place and we went back down to
this degree of disorder here,
it doesn't matter, it's a
state function, all we care
about is the actual difference
between our starting point
and our ending point.
And I just can't resist putting
in a little quote,
"something there is that doesn't
love a wall." Does
anybody know where this quote
is from -- very famous poem,
very famous poet.
Good guesses, parents
can help with this.
Yes, excellent.
I've never heard the correct
answer this question before.
Excellent.
So this is Robert Frost
in The Mending Wall.
He talks about, it sounds like
a lot of you did know this,
this makes me full of joy.
"Something there is that
doesn't love a wall," there's
many interpretations for this
poem, but maybe it's
about entropy.
Entropy doesn't love a wall,
we're going from order to
disorder, that wall wants
to come down.
All right.
So let's formalize these
thoughts on entropy and in
terms of what we're
talking about.
Again, what I said on that's
chart there is as we increase
entropy, we're increasing
disorder.
So if you saw a positive
change in entropy in a
reaction, would you think about
that as being more or
less ordered?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so it's
actually going to be less
ordered, and, in fact, I should
stop saying order, I
should be just saying disorder
because disorder's actually
what we're measuring, and
there's an increase in
disorder here when we have a
positive change in enthalpy.
So if we have a negative change
in enthalpy, we're
going to see a decrease
in disorder.
So in terms of considering
different types of states that
we can be in, whether we're in
a gas state or a liquid state
or a solid state for any given
molecule or any given
compound, we can think about
how much order or disorder
these states have. So which of
these three states would you
call the most disordered?
STUDENT: Gas.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it's
the gas state.
So it turns out that the
disorder gas is greater than
liquid., which is greater
than solid.
This makes sense and the gas
molecules are free to bounce
around, go wherever they want.
Once you're in a liquid, they
have a little bit more
limitation, they can't
go anywhere.
But the molecules can still
slide all around
and pass each other.
Once you're in a solid state,
this molecule is not going to
flip places with the other
molecules there.
It's going to be kind of stuck
in its place within the solid.
So, just understanding this
explanation of entropy that
we're going to have an increase
in entropy if we have
an increase in disorder, allows
us to make predictions
about reactions even without
doing any calculations, and we
always like when that happens,
because then once we do
calculations, we can check our
calculations and make sure
they make sense with what
we would be predicting.
So before we talk about how to
actually do a calculation,
let's go to a clicker question
here and make sure everyone is
on the same page in terms of
thinking about changes in
entropy or changes or delta
s for the reaction.
So let's say we're talking about
the decomposition of
hydrogen peroxide into
water and oxygen.
I want you to tell me if you
think it's going to have a
positive delta s, a negative,
or zero, or maybe this will
change with temperature
as well.
All right, so let's go
ahead and take 10
seconds on this one.
OK, excellent.
Great job with the
questions today.
So we are actually going to see
a positive delta s. this
should be very clear because
we're going from two moles of
liquid, to now having two moles
of liquid, plus a mole
of gas, so we're going to be
increasing the disorder of our
system here.
All right, so let's think about
how we actually can
calculate, though, delta s.
So far I've just been giving
you the delta s's for the
reactions, but, as I'm sure you
can guess, you won't be
given that information, for
example, on upcoming
problem-sets, you'll actually
need to calculate the entropy.
So what we can do is we can
actually calculate the entropy
of a reaction from absolute
entropies of individual
molecules that we're
discussing.
So this is very similar to how
we calculated the enthalpy of
a reaction by taking the
change of enthalpy of
formation, except we don't even
have to worry about a
change in entropy because we can
talk about entropy as an
absolute value.
There's an absolute zero in
terms of entropy where there
is no disorder at all.
And this is described for any
molecule as being its perfect
crystal at absolute zero.
So this is what we're going to
say there's absolute complete
order, there's no disorder
at all in this system.
So what we can take to calculate
the entropy in a
reaction, is just to take the
sum of the entropy of all the
products, and subtract from that
the entropy from all of
the reactants.
So let's try this for the
example that you just did on
the clicker question, and make
sure that our calculation
matches up with our
prediction here.
So again, we're just going to
take the sum of the entropy of
the products minus out
of the reactants.
So if we talk about this,
we're starting with our
product, so our first
product is water.
And what I want to point out is
you need to make sure you
multiply this by 2, because, in
fact, we have two moles of
water that are formed here.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK, I'm so sorry.
Yeah, so yikes, this
should be water.
You know what, let's just
write this on the board.
So we're going to talk about
delta s of the reaction.
So that's to be sum of the
entropy of the products.
So we're going to be talking
about 2 times entropy of
water, and we'll add to that
our other product, which is
molecular oxygen here, and we
don't need to put a number out
here because it's
just one mole.
So that's of o 2, and we'll
subtract from that, the
entropy of hydrogen
peroxide here.
And do we need to put anything
out here for this?
STUDENT: 2.
PROFESSOR: So, yeah, because
there's two moles there.
So water plus oxygen minus
hydrogen peroxide.
Let's hope I at least got
the values right.
Yeah, and actually I think this
is right, I believe this
is the entropy of water.
So OK, so the actual numbers
are right here for what is
written on the board and
hopefully in your notes.
So what we find out is that the
entropy of this reaction
here, the change in entropy, the
delta s, is 125 joules per
k per mole.
All right, so we can also --
well, first, we already
thought about why delta
s is positive.
Delta s is positive because
we're going from a liquid to a
liquid and a gas -- we're
increasing our disorder.
So let's think about whether
this reaction is spontaneous
or not, and to do that, we
actually need to go ahead and
completely calculate delta g.
So to do this, we can take our
values here, and delta g is
equal to delta h minus
t delta s.
So if we plug all of this in,
we have our delta h is
negative 196 kilojoules per
mole, minus our temperature,
and I wanted you to write this
again, because I want to make
sure you get in the habit of
converting our joules to
kilojoules.
It's 0 .
125 kilojoules per
kelvin mole.
So we end up with a delta
g of negative 233
kilojoules per mole.
Is that spontaneous or
non-spontaneous?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Great.
So the reaction here
is spontaneous.
So actually, this is probably
a reaction that you're
familiar with because a lot of
us do have hydrogen peroxide
just in our medicine cabinet.
And if you go and look at the
expiration date on your
hydrogen peroxide, you
will see that it
does, in fact, expire.
And you might think oh no, what
happens when it expires,
when it goes bad?
All that's happening is it's
turning into water.
So I wouldn't drink it after
its expiration date, but
probably there's more
water than hydrogen
peroxide at that point.
But it also actually brings out
a really important point
about thermodynamics, which is
that thermodynamics, in fact,
tells us if a reaction happening
in the forward
direction is spontaneous
or non-spontaneous.
So, for example, we see
that yes, it is
a spontaneous reaction.
But you'll note that
thermodynamics tells us
absolutely nothing about the
timeframe of that reaction.
So some reactions that are
spontaneous take place in a
matter of seconds or
microseconds or less.
Other reactions, such as this,
to have an appreciable amount
of that reaction go forward,
it actually takes years.
You'll notice that it's not
just one day before that
hydrogen peroxide expires.
It's takes a really long time to
get a significant amount of
this reaction to go.
So just make sure, we will get
to talking about kinetics,
which does tell us about the
timeframe of chemical reactions.
But don't confuse
thermochemistry or
thermodynamics with kinetics.
It doesn't matter how huge our
delta g is in terms of being
if it's negative two or if it's
negative two million,
that still doesn't tell
us how fast the
reaction's going to go.
All right.
So let's think about one more
example here in terms of
thinking about entropy.
So another example we talked
about was the melting of ice
at room temperature.
I think all of us agree that
this is spontaneous, but that
the enthalpy change
is positive, it's
an endothermic reaction.
So we can think about
calculating the entropy here,
and I'm happy to see that I did,
in fact, put the products
h 2 o here as a liquid,
subtracting the reactant,
which is h 2 o as a solid.
If we go ahead and plug in those
values here, what we end
up with is a delta s of
this reaction of 28 .
59 joules.
This makes sense because we're
increasing the disorder of the
system, we're seeing a positive
delta s here.
And I just answered that
question for you.
We're going why is
delta s positive?
We're going from a
solid to liquid,
we're increasing disorder.
So, we can calculate delta g as
well, and if we do this we
plug in these numbers here.
What we end up with is that
delta g equals negative 1 .
57 kilojoules per mole.
So it is spontaneous, delta
g is just barely negative.
And what actually is the case,
which we'll talk about more on
Monday and thinking more and
more about how temperature
actually affects these
reactions, but what we know
about melting of ice is that
it is, in fact, temperature
dependent, right.
Ice doesn't melt at just
any old temperature.
So that's where temperature
actually comes into play here.
All right.
So we have a case --
spontaneous, even though delta
h is positive.
All right, so let's think also
about how we can go about
calculating the free energy
of formation.
So we know that we can use the
equation that we saw in terms
of the free energy the reaction,
but what if we're
actually thinking about the free
energy of the formation
of a particular molecule?
So that's actually completely
analogous to thinking about
the enthalpy of formation, or
it's basically the standard
Gibbs free energy
of formation.
So this is talking about forming
a mole of a compound
from its most stable elements,
from its elements in their
most stable states at pressure
of one bar and at room
temperature.
So we know that we can tabulate
it must like we
tabulated delta h formation,
but we can also tabulate it
from this reaction here, which
it looks like I already told
you this reaction, which I did
but I told you a more general
form, which was for the free
energy of a reaction.
This is the free energy of
a reaction, which is the
formation of a certain compound,
and this is the free
energy of formation equals
the enthalpy of formation
minus t delta s.
So let's think about why it is
important to be thinking about
these changes of free energy
in terms of forming a
molecule, and it's important
because the delta g
information is actually a
measure of how stable or
unstable a molecule is relative
to its element.
So, for example, if something
is really stable relative to
its elements, we can think
about whether delta g of
formation should be negative
or positive.
So let's have you do one last
clicker question here, and
tell me what do you think, if
delta g of formation, of
actually forming a molecule is
going to be negative, would
you say that the compound is
going to be stable or unstable
relative to the elements that
that compound is made up of?
All right, let's take
10 seconds on this.
OK, interesting.
So this is going to be another
tie breaker for us.
So let's go back to the notes
and think about this.
So it turns out that it's going
to be stable, relative
to its -- the compound
is stable
relative to its elements.
And the reason for this is if
you think of the reaction of
the elements forming the
compound, if the delta g of
that reaction is negative,
that means it's going to
spontaneously form
the compound.
It's going to go -- release
energy when it actually forms
that compound.
So that's another way of telling
us that the compound
is more stable than
its elements.
So conversely, if we have delta
g of formation being
greater than zero, so delta g
of formation is just delta g
of the reaction where the
compound is formed, then what
we find is that it's
thermodynamically unstable
relative to its elements,
because instead of releasing
energy in that reaction, you
actually have to put energy
into that reaction in order
to make it happen.
So, delta g of formation can
give us an indication of
whether we have a stable or
an unstable compound.